hey hey you can ask IJ actually this is
gonna be more of a reverse ask a J
episode because I asked you guys what I
should do to get healthy for the GE
Howcast YouTube physical challenge I got
so many suggestions and comments of
things to do for this challenge I could
only pick a few so for this episode I'm
going to do the read of your suggestions
when I first read this comment by X
beauty products X I thought that's gonna
be really easy walk around with an apple
on my head you said run around with an
apple on my head but yeah walking around
the Apple owner has a lot easier when
it's not windy outside hundred one Brook
and mix tabular both want me to dance
now if you've seen any of my videos
before you know that that's probably one
of my favorite things to do
granted I'm not very good at it that
makes it all the more fun to enjoy the
people's reactions watching you try to
dance
oh my goodness
this challenge was probably the most
difficult for me
strike media prod wanted me to eliminate
drinking caffeine for an entire week
[Music]
alright so that was my first set of
challenges now I'm extremely excited
because my next challenge is going to be
absolutely amazing and I can't wait to
show it to you guys I was completely
blown away with all of your great
suggestions and knowledge on things to
do to get healthy if you want to find
out more information about this contest
or see who else is participating check
out youtube.com slash podcast thanks so
much
and I will see you guys soon
[Music]